before the break we heard from the
Chancellor Philip Hammond so let's get
some reaction to that interview we're
joined from some set by the conservative
honcho Jacob Riis mark thank you very
much for being with us
I know you've night to listen to a bit
of that interview one of the things that
really struck me from what the
Chancellor was saying was that if there
isn't a deal he said that he'd have to
set out a new budget next year and
actually strike out in a different
direction with the economy what do you
make of that it's not something you'd
welcome or is that something that
worries you well I would have thought it
would be better to take the
opportunities ahead of us now rather
than waiting this doesn't sound like
George Osborne's punishment budget do
you remember that we were going to get a
punishment budget
immediately after the referendum if we
had the audacity debate to leave there
sounds like a approach where policy
decisions would be made to embrace
brexit and I'd be very much in favor of
that being done on Monday rather than
waiting a few months and does it concern
you then because from what Philip
Hammond was saying there he was talking
about actually setting out some of the
more specific details in the spending
review next year you'd like to see more
happening right now and you worried that
the perhaps the budget might be a bit of
a non-event well with lack of a majority
I think the budget will not be enormous
ly radical I think that's pretty widely
accepted I thought a lot of what the
Chancellor was saying and your very
interesting interview was important and
would be beneficial for the economy but
I think we should be making
announcements now about how we would
deal with leaving on well trade
organization terms for instance why
don't we get rid of all tariffs on goods
that we don't produce in this country on
the 29th of March at 2019 to show that
we're open to the world that we're going
to be a global nation rather than a
peripheral European nation do you think
the Chancellor could be a bit of an ally
in this or do you think that he's
someone who perhaps is not seizing the
benefits of breakfast oh look the
Treasury has been the bastion of
remainer ism
since the referendum and indeed before
it came out with all these lunatic
forecasts before the referendum as to
what would happen
purely on a vote Tilly bear in mind the
Treasury said very 800,000 job losses
potentially just on voting to leave
before anything had happened so the
Treasury's rather embarrassed itself has
a lot of egg on its face from getting
its brakes it related forecasts so wrong
so far and I think there is an element
within the Treasury that is still grumpy
about breaks it and that's a pity at the
same time and from the Chancellor's
interview it may be that here's of
course I'm speculating here he may be
talking about actually seizing the
opportunities of brakes that if there is
a no deal as you would see seeds and
opportunities others would see and
perhaps trying to deal with some of the
economic issues of ranks it by perhaps
lowering taxes trying to attract
business trying to change regulations is
that something that you'd welcome or do
fear it may actually put off motors on
the center ground III think that
approach is something the government
should be doing anyway that we want to
be a competitive Latex economy open to
the world and it's really interesting
that the Treasury did a dynamic
assessment of the tax revenues that
would come from cutting corporation tax
and reduced corporation tax from 28% to
19% and has seen the revenue increase by
over 50% so lower tax rates can lead to
more tax revenue helping both the
economy and improving public services
now the Chancellor did talk about this
some time ago when he said one of the
options was for the UK to be more like
Singapore and although that's not a
perfect comparison because Singapore is
a small city-state there are lessons we
can learn from other countries about the
economic approach we could take look
what's happened in America with the
significant tax cuts a year ago and an
absolutely booming economy if you cut
taxation you can have more money
available for public services a lower
deficit and better economic growth so I
think that's an opportunity that should
be taken regardless of brexit at the
same time even if you accept your
assertion that cutting taxes may benefit
the economy in the long term which of
course lots of people would refute it
entirely in the short term that doesn't
work that means less money doesn't it
that means ending austerity may become
more difficult to do now and after 10
years of austerity many people are
absolutely desperate basically
for those you know belt belt-tightening
to be loosened no no dare I say there
are two things that mustn't be confused
here
one is the total tax taker and the other
is tax rates that you saw with
corporation tax which is a very close
example in time but you've seen it with
other rates in the past that a lower
rate can lead to a higher tax take
providing more money for public services
at the point at which you did if you
look at the reverse you will see that
the very high rates of stamp duty have
lowered the tax take so tax taken tax
rates do not go hand-in-hand and that is
not a long-term issue it's an immediate
issue and I would be advocating looking
at rates doing dynamic assessments of
the effects that changing rates will
have so that you get lower rates where
they work and will produce more revenue
which i think would happen incidentally
with stamp duty - and now of course not
long to wait until we know more about
what's in the budget we've had some
announcements around things like new
high streets around roads what would you
like to see in the budget tomorrow
well I'm speculating on what will be the
new budget 24 hours before it's out is
is a bit of a fool's errand but I would
like to see the transyl and make
announcements getting us absolutely
ready for leaving on the 29th of March
so as I said cutting customs duties on
all goods that we don't produce in this
country for example would be something
we could do
cutting the v80 rates on products where
we're forced to have v80 rates because
of EU regulations so that they would go
so what are we talking about domestic
fuel women sanitary products and solar
panels and things like that where
there's a clear advantage to not having
v80 on them now in last weekend's papers
we heard some pretty ugly language
directed towards the Prime Minister and
killing zones talk of the knife being
twisted I mean it was pretty lurid
violent imagery were you disturbed to
read the comments of some of your
colleagues and what would be your
message to them my message would be and
that politics can be discussed in a
robust but polite way that the Prime
Minister is very good at this she makes
her views very clear but is never
personally abuse
and I think that's how politics should
be carried out I'm afraid I think these
terms are rather juvenile and indicate a
lack of seriousness about politics that
politics is not war politics is a
democratic debate to try and carry the
country along with whatever policies are
being advocated and to talk of it in
terms of war zones and things like that
is frankly pretty silly and just before
you go and mr. Reese morgue and last
week I spoke to some young conservatives
in Cambridge and they were basically
talking about you and rather glowing
terms saying you should be the person
who should be the next leader of the
Conservative Party I mean would you rule
out running did you manage to find my
six children in Cambridge because I can
only think they'd be the young people
who would advocate such a view you're
very flattering but but but now my
ambition is purely for brexit to be
delivered it's not personal it's about
the policy being delivered correctly and
so I'm not a candidate there isn't a
vacancy and I wouldn't see myself as a
serious candidate way as a backbench MP